Hello Everybody!
My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Manual Samuel
now, I know it's been a while since the last episode
And I apologize for that (aww Markimoo)
I may have already talked about it, but this last week has been awesome
in terms of me making videos and all that sort of stuff
and I mEANT TO GET BACK TO IT!
MUCH SOONER
Because I actually adore this game
Because it is STUPID, and - (off track) du -duh don't hit that bird..
don't hit that bird...
okay good
I thought it was gonna *scree* oh gowd....
and I meant to get back to it a lot sooner (no one cares what death says)
(mark listening to the cringey voice of death)
how?
how..?
(mark listening to the narrator)
Yeah, no not really..
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I think I'd already know...  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
//subtitle artist gets shot \\
(more useless listening when we can read it on the screen)
a'ight
*( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  INTENSIFIES*
What is that supposed to mean? (poor innocent mark...)
I don't know what that means..? (Innocent Mark)
Right clutch
oh god.....
you know I may have spoken too soon about this being-
(more cringey death voices)
yeah..... (doesn't know what to make of the situation)
okay...
(random insult)
oooOOHKAY *le cringe*
(we know how to drive a car dude.... or most of us do...)
wwHHHAAATT?
OH GOWD
Okay I may have spoken too soon about this game being charming and fun
because
APPARENTLY
I'm not gonna be able to do a whole lotta this...
(you make no sense stfu)
Nice?!
okayyyy
Alright will do as soon as I remember to breath and blink properly while doing this
HERB-A-DERP
I know how to drive a manual
uh huh (not taking his bullshit)
okay-oh boy
Oh boy
HOW AM I GONNA DO THE STICK?!
OOOOHHH GGOOODDDD
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*Cringey death-like noises*
How- wha- left shift?
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
WWWHHHAATTT??
Ooookkaayy
WHHAATT?
Okay, nope, that ain't workin'
I probably gotta downshift back to first gear
Cause i know how this works ( of course you do )
okay
Here we go!
(Weird Markimoo car noises)
oh aaAAHHHHHHHH
I'm going right! I can't go right!
I did! I did stop!!
AAHHH
That old lady has so many cameras on her face... why? (maybe she's famous)
oh okay
How? How?
HHEEHHH?
Okay, Alright (confused) IDK HOW I'M GONNA BE ABLE TO DO THIS BUT I'M GONNA-
Clitch... (wtf mark?)
subtitle artist gets stabbed
A little bit yeah!
uh huh?
Yeah- DON'T BE DISTRACTED
WHOA- Wuu
Not alot
hang on-
uh huh (not paying attention)
okkayyyy
what?
okay, hang on
I DON'T KNOW
NOOO
i don't wanna shortcut :C
(CONFUSED MARK NOISES)
wha-? okai-
Did I do it? Uh..
okay
Oh.. oh...
AAHHHH
(CONFUSED MARK) I gotta blink and breath!!
Ahhh
Yaayy!
Well, did they kill each other?!
okay...?
okay I guess we're done!?
(don't speak so soon, you've learned your lessson once)
YYAAYY!!
HORRAY!!
WOO~
OH hi~~!
NICE
NICE!!
Okay..
(Definately need to stick with that one)
(I spoke too soon)
(Markimoo cringing)
Wh-why? Why? Why does this person have a skull face?
And also boobs? (for the entertainment)
That's the only thing I'm not getting on this- Everything else I'm fine with-
heyy~~~
How you doin'? (smooth marki)
okay... (rejected)
Alrighty then..
We're off M-(troubles)M'lady
M-M'lady... (unsure whether it's a lady)
GONNA BLINK AND BREATH DON'T MIND ME
uh huh
Yeah! Hell Yeah!!
woo- Hang on..
(BRAKING MARKIMOO NOISES)
Alright.. THANK YOU GLAD I COULD HELP
I don't know how I'm helping, but okay- alright..
Welp, here we go then...
WWHHAATT?!
Ugghh FIINEE JESUS
ehhh.. why is there war on the streets right outside-
Samuel's house?
I'm not- uh- sure I'm on top of everything here but alright..
UUGHH
Wha-??
Oh Jeez-
Why- Why is she concerned about smoking?!
Are we gonna meet pestilence and all the other ones too? (that's be hella fuckin cool)
//get's shot\\
Alright..
I'm a good driver! (sure Mark)
This is a weird day for Samuel
oh- whu
I-
I WAS TRYING ;-;
Okie, there ya go..
JEEZUMS
I don't know if I should be okay with this!!
Alright, okay, we'll just carry on with your mer-(fucked up) wanted murder..
Okay, and your cigarette that seems to be burning a hole in me car (rip car)
*sexy Mark voice* yeahh~~
mmMMMMmm
YOU GOT IT
Why am I even going this fast anyway.. do I need to go this fast.?
I mean I know I'm over-achieving here..
You got it! lemme just take another breath-y blink-y breath!
break
Of we go M- m'lady (still unsure on gender by appearance)
Oh no
I'll keep it in second gear
Uhh
Why are the grandmas in a worn-torn area? (that's actually a good question)
OKAY, ALRIGHT GOODBYE
Alright... goodbye..
BRO
YOU GOTTA PLAY IT COOL MAN (marki giving girlfriend advice)
you can't be so..
*tries not to crush death's heart*
You can't be coming on so STRONGLY
ALRIGHT
I- I don't know if I can
Hang on I gotta figure out my wheels
There we go
As hard as we can, huh?
I can go pretty hard ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I'm going fast!
This is maximum speed!!
Wait, no- This is it's maximum speed!!
I AM IN FIFTH GEAR
WHAT DO YOU THINK I AM
AN IDIOT? A guy who can't flirt with war? (no u can't mark)
I AM
okay..
ohhh huhu
OOHHHH
okay..? (wtf is that hashtag?)
ookaay
Alright..
Is it? Oh.. hi
ooohhh nooo...
uhuh
NOO
I DIDN'T BLINK AT ALL
nope
not- uh uh
cavin' in on myself!!
THERE'S NO WAY YOU'RE GONNA GET MY SHRED OF LIFE
IT AIN'T GONNA HAPPEN
I'LL BREATHE
BUT I AIN'T GONNA BLINK
NNNOOOOPE
nope
yeah we're doing this
Of course we're doing this- why wouldn't we be doing this? You're not gonna get my breath-
(fucked up again)
shred of life
shred breath
(good job covering it up Marki)
shred breath..?
no no no no
nope
ehh no
why would we?
i mean, it's obvious the shred if life is very VALUABLE to me
so WHHYYYY
Would I readily give it up
S-so death, who has proven to be a-
a- a- a dick!
Oh hello
Sam, Sammy?
Sammy are you-
S- sam *le worried*
Sam?
Saaamm?
FUCK THIS GUY (uhhh)
HOLD ON SAM
HOLD ON
HOLD OOOONNNNNN
GRAB MY HAND!!
TAKE MY HAND!!
HOLD ONNN!!
GRAB MY HAND!!
Oh boy (mumbling markimoo)
i guess..
blink..?
OOOHHH OKAY FINE
You talkin' about masturbation? (really mark? >XD)
Okay, yeah, a LITTLE weird
I mean, I don't even know if that would be possible!
57 times?! Holy shit!!
Yaayyy (not convincing)
okay....
WOOO
okay
okai
alright
Yeah that sounds pretty good!
but either way
This is gonna have to wait until the next episode
I am gonna finish this up VERY soon
so you can expect *mumbling* regular videos
of this coming out
IN THE NEAR FUTURE
So thank you so much everybody for watching
And as always!! I will see you~
in the next video!
bye-Bye!!!
(dat outro tho)
BYEEEE!!!!